as a mom of kids that are black I worry
about this stuff every single day from
the time they were born this has been
something that as a mom I've had been on
my radar Holly Robinson Peete is one of
Hollywood's most dedicated activists
working hard to enact change with the
black lives matter movement especially
when it comes to her 22 year old son RJ
who has autism we're starting this
initiative for RJ's law which
essentially would have notification on
driver's license to indicate that the
driver has autism or is on the autism
spectrum
the 21 Jumpstreet star joins ET for a
wide-ranging interview and not only does
she reveal the secret to her 25 year
long marriage to former NFL pro Rodney
Peete people say marriage is 50/50 I say
marriage is 100 100
she also praises their 22 year-old
daughter Ryan who came out publicly as
gay during Pride Month I was just proud
of her she's a spectacular young lady
Holly is also busy as ever with three
new Hallmark Channel projects and even
teases if she'd ever make a return to
daytime TV I absolutely loved daytime TV
I'm wide open to it I would never say no
when the last you know month and a half
there have been protests against racism
protests against police brutality how
did you feel going through this whole
movement this black lives matter
movement well so as a black mom of four
I have you know this isn't my first
rodeo right but as a mom of kids that
are black I worry about this stuff every
single day from the time they were born
this has been something that as a mom
I've haven't been on my radar and so it
wasn't like some new thing I think what
happened with this is just you know
between the pandemic is the sadness and
the coolness of this one incident in the
timing of it really you know helped kick
this movement forward that said like I
just as a mom this has been something I
worry about a lot
about four years ago when RJ my son with
autism started driving it was a big deal
because they said he would never drive
and when he started driving I was
worried about him every time you got me
on the wheel because what happens if he
gets pulled over he has autism he's
porkies different how does he respond to
demands and commands and how do I keep
him alive because we've seen that that
can end bad and so we were starting this
initiative for our RJ's law which
essentially would have notification on
driver's license and maybe in some cases
on even license plates to indicate that
the driver the registered owner has
autism or is on the autism spectrum and
maybe just maybe that will affected the
exchange between the officer and the
driver I started talking about this for
years ago and there wasn't a whole lot
of appetite to hear the conversation
then but I think maybe now the timing is
everything I think we're ready I think
we're longer yeah people are because
when I tried to talk about it four years
ago people were like what do you mean
that doesn't happen like you know you
should just say I have autism and the
cotton-like no it doesn't work like that
only it was that simple yeah so I'm very
very proud of the concept of Arty's law
and that we're gonna keep moving forward
on that so more about that soon that's
that's exciting and truly thank you for
thinking of not only your son but all
the other kids in the world who are
going through those similar experiences
I'm curious what do those conversations
look like and sound like if they do
happen to you know God forbid get into a
confrontation with law enforcement look
and sound like this comply don't talk
back you know put your hands where they
can be seen start your phone definitely
always record it make sure their body
cam is on but this is a lot to ask a
child to do if you're being stopped is
scary we've also had former policemen
come over to our house and talk to our
kids and like you know actually role
playing and do things like that and my
son just went to Western Bay
this morning I took his little thing he
wants he loves to go to and he goes to
Western bagel and you know I had to give
him a you know 10-minute rundown and he
was just like yes mom yes mom this is
what I do that's what I do and I love it
now that they just listen
right they used to look roll their eyes
like they know and they know that we're
looking out for them so we need to do
things you know in honor of our kids not
a memory of them we don't want something
bad to happen to them my son said to me
other day mom I thought you said if I
complied everything would be okay
George Floyd complied and he he died and
so then I go back to the drawing board
again you know so that's really the
biggest issue are we really listening to
black moms and black dads when we're
talking about keeping our kids state if
it was your child and this was happening
to your child and it wasn't happening to
my child I would be just concerned I'd
be out there in these streets
I'd be like uh-huh because your child is
just as important as my child your child
life matters my child life matters so
that's the message I think we've been
trying to get out there and I feel like
more people are listening and that's a
good thing we're talking about your kids
here I would love to just shift to you
for a second being a black woman in
Hollywood I'm curious if you have a
particular memory or an experience where
racism really kind of confronted you
head on as far as casting and getting
roles I've been very blessed in that way
I think where I've seen discrimination
is just really in the pay Viola Davis
had a viral video about it recently and
I have a career that's probably
comparable to Meryl Streep Julianne
Moore lets Sigourney Weaver they had the
same path as me and yet I am nowhere
near them not as far as money not as as
far as job opportunities nowhere close
to it I felt that all the way down to my
toenails I was like whoa girl like you
ain't never lied the way black actresses
are paid compared to some other
actresses this it's it's unbelievably
disproportionate and so that's that's
just the truth
and I love that Biola's said it in the
way that she said it cuz only viola
could say it that way and that probably
be the one area where you know I've
looked at things and gone well that's
I'm not fair
I think nowadays we're really embracing
the diversity of who we are as actresses
and actors and so I love seeing so much
natural hair and so on you know we are
not one person we are not one actor we
are not you know as black people we we
are very diverse the more diverse ways
that you see us presented and
represented in show business I think the
better you'll get to know who who black
people are as as a whole I want to
transition a little and talk a little
bit about your beautiful family
specifically your daughter Ryan she
posted such a heartfelt coming-out story
in honor of Pride Month last month yeah
I know it's her story to tell but I'm
curious if you would share a little bit
maybe about her journey and how you as a
parent and how Rodney as a parent have
navigated that you know all I can do is
honor my daughter's truth and I was
really proud of her that she posted that
it's important that we celebrate our
kids and love who they love and support
what they support she did it in our own
time in her own way she's spectacular
young lady and she felt like she needed
to do that not everybody does but she
felt like she needed to speak her truth
and I'm just there for her 100% and her
dad as well and we got amazing responses
some of our family friends that reached
out just really touched us so I'm just
super proud of Ryan and you know I want
her to just be happy and like us all we
want for our kids is just to be happy
and feel comfortable in their own skin
you have been married for 25 years I
have to congratulate you on this big
milestone anniversary that you just
celebrated what does it feel to reach
such a pivotal point in your marriage
we're kind of bummed because obviously
it's such a big milestone of 25 years
fell during this pandemic and we
couldn't have that big you know splashy
a celebration that we wanted to have we
were gonna go to Mexico a friend of mine
has a hotel we were gonna bring couples
we're gonna do it big but yeah that
turned into a socially distant serenade
by Jeffrey Osborne 25 years is a really
big deal what is the secret for us it's
about being on the same page right
sometimes we you know as people you
drift and you you have to make a
conscious effort to stay together and
stay focused on what's important in your
marriage and so you know people say
marriage is 50/50 I say marriage is 100
100 meaning you gotta give a hundred
percent of yourself under percent of the
time and you've got to constantly be on
the same page so that's not always easy
we call it same page love and if you can
achieve that great I've been really
fortunate that you know Ronnie and I
have been able to to stay on the same
page most of our marriage fall off a
page here and there sometimes we're not
even in the same book but let alone
what's an experience that you guys have
have had in your past where maybe you
did fall off and you're you were on
different pages how do you get through
that we believe and have always believed
in therapists and and licensed marriage
counselors because let me just tell you
like anything you need guidance you're
not always gonna be in the same place as
your husband you're not always gonna you
know you know he's gonna feel like
talking about things in a productive way
and I have found over the years that
when we get off the page and
we sit down with her she was able to
walk us through things that we would not
have seen if you were just going back
and forth with each other I have an a
football player you know who retired
after 16 years that brought a whole
nother level of you know scrutiny on our
marriage because he was used to doing
something on slights and that hits those
guys very hard but that was an issue our
son's autism was a big issue how do we
process that there are a lot of things
that happened in the course of 25 years
that put us at odds with each other and
so we're always going to sit down and
figure out what that looks like and once
you do that if you're both willing to
say hey we won't do what it takes to
move forward with this then great but
you got to give yourself that shot will
you marry me
yes I will
[Music]
through all of the chaos going on in the
world right now you have still managed
to find a way to be one of the busiest
women in Hollywood you have so many
projects at the Hallmark Channel I have
truly lost track trust me as a as a old
girl who's been doing this a long time
but somebody says you got three movies
coming up you know I am like on my knees
thanking God because I'm very very
blessed to be able to be working even
right now we have Christmas in July
going and it's been fun watching you
know some of my evergreen movies now we
got evergreen for coming up so that's
gonna be that's gonna be really cool and
just the idea that we have content that
lifts us it gives us good feels right
now much needed 1,000% and some of that
content that I especially love is
watching you opposite Rick Fox in
morning show mysteries there's a new
exhibit at the Science Museum we should
go see it this weekend that sounds like
fun
we are so excited to get back going in
the morning show mysteries franchise
just want to remind everybody that
morning show mysteries come from the
creative mind of the Renaissance man
himself Al Roker naw he predicted
weather but he could executive produce
murder mysteries this guy and cook and
grow a garden and he's just an awesome
guy he's been a friend for years and I
love working with him and somewhere a
tional mysteries we're gonna pick up
where we left off Billy blessings is a
chef author and television personality
and she's super nosy and always he's
trying to you know get in somebody's
kool-aid without knowing the flavor so I
love that about her and a little bit
like me working with Rick it's just
really really difficult because you know
when you got a look at Rick Fox all day
long yeah how do you do it how do you
cope
I don't know pearl you know somebody got
to do it I could take one for the team
no but he's also a dear friend so that's
super fun in my humble opinion there's
never enough Holly Robinson Peete on
television so I know you've got your
hand in like a milli
different Hallmark Channel projects but
I do want to ask you because not one but
two seats have now opened up on the
daytime talk show the real would you
ever reconsider joining daytime TV again
I absolutely loved daytime TV when I did
the talk many years ago I felt like it
was like a pair socks like I just felt
so comfortable in that role you know
unfortunately that situation wasn't
quite right for me which is cool and you
know you live and learn but subsequently
I've I've looked and entertained some
ideas about doing some daytime so I'm
wide open to it I would never say no
[Music]